hello there a year ago I made a video
about fortnite facts and I think it's
time for part two and more useless
information let's see how many of the
following you knew oh and of course
before we start insert code adamaru
begging here thank you
did you know the original customizable
skin in fortnite Maya found in the
battle pass back in Chapter 2 season 2
was said to have 3.8 million style
options yet someone did the maths and in
fact there are 9.2 million unique
combinations and style options for her
9.2 what does yours look like mine's
this I didn't change a thing when
swimming was added to fortnite the game
developers used the movie Don't Mess
with the Zohan as reference for the
over-the-top nature of the animation
over in fortnite save the world it's
possible to find skins referencing
different movies and icons Kyle has a
Friday the 13th costume complete with
hockey mask and Jess has a beetlejess
costume if you haven't seen Beetlejuice
by saying his name three times in a row
it will summon him to your location I
dare you to say it sticking with save
the world did you know Chaos Agent has
voice lines listen something's floating
in that incubation tube turns out in
this reality he's a Russian scientist
see season zero of Battle Royale had the
most insane secret to be found at the
shipping crate hidden at the very bottom
was this a tiny cabbage making machine
in a suitcase to this day I still don't
know what this represents epic games
must give us answers soon during chapter
2 another mind-boggling item appeared
under steamy Stacks this freaky item was
hidden behind a wall giving off this
weird sound
it was revealed to be a crossover with
the movie tenet and this is part of the
algorithm which is extremely important
to the plot a fortnight crossover that
was hinted at but never arrived was for
the movie it that scary clown's Red
Balloons could be seen floating tied to
sewer drains and if they were destroyed
we'd hear this but the full crossover
for the It movie never arrived the
shortest crossover in fortnite history
is from Wreck-It Ralph who was
technically in the game for less than
five seconds walking through the frame
at risky reels luckily we were given an
emote to remember the absolute unit that
Ralph is the legend of peely is
constantly growing as without him the io
would have won the war against the seven
four weeks before the Collision event
peely was learning how to drive and
constantly failed luckily when defeat
looked imminent for our Mech peely
rocked up and saved the day handing over
some sweet slurp juice so if anyone asks
who's the most important character in
fortnite it's peely but to get to this
point he's endured some bad times being
the character eliminated the most in
fortnite trailers he was tracked down
and frozen in carbonite by the
Mandalorian he was yated out of
existence by Darth Vader on the roller
coaster peely didn't have a chance to
react to an Indiana Jones set off the
boulder he was taken out by Vader again
when a door malfunctioned during a Star
Wars crossover and his most gruesome
death of all came at the hands of Ryu as
Jonesy ran to join the seven and of
course there was that time his best
friend Jonesy made him into a smoothie
to save his own life peely's been
through some things and if you're
wondering how he came into existence it
was thanks to John Z messing with an
unreliable sideways Rift combining his
DNA with a banana he was eating at the
time fortnite is weird when fortnite
added a zero build mode in Chapter 3 The
Eagle eyed in the background noticed
tomato head being eliminated by Fall
damage it turns out that was a nod to
Tim the tatman and his favorite skin and
his constant dying to fall damage the
war themed season coincided with a very
real war in the Ukraine so epic gave
revenue from the game to Charities over
there to assist
144 million dollars in total which is
5.3 billion parivnia I think I said that
right Ukrainian money is during that
season a llama was created with shipping
crates and the Ukraine flag made up the
bulk of it showing support in-game nice
talk in the last episode we looked at
the first two gravestones added to
fortnite to commemorate player's
stupidity since then two more have been
found a crater was found with a
gravestone commemorating Jack grass and
his Squad who used a glitch to throw
themselves across the map they went
further than expected and Jack didn't
survive the other gravestone saw a car
wreck halfway into the ground with
flowers and two graves nearby this one
is for rust 9k who drove a vehicle into
a rift and then glitched through the
ground eliminating him and his passenger
instantly R.I.P we all know about DVD
screensavers and the bouncing icon we
longed to hit one of the corners
perfectly in fortnite the i o have the
very same screensaver with their own
logo and if you're wondering it can
indeed hit the corner it's so satisfying
[Applause]
do you know what day of the week it was
when agent Jones last jumped into the
zero point before switching allegiance
to the seven well in imposters mode we
can visit his room and see his wardrobe
and the suits he wears each day and the
last one he wore was a Tuesday so this
happened on a Tuesday useless
information but kinda called to did you
know that a fan named the Colombo
species when the image of this creature
was first released a chap on Reddit
whose name I can't pronounce proclaimed
I shall call him clombo I want to Plush
of him the Devon charge liked that name
and it became law and then a Colombo
dance was found in the files too if we
emoted nearby as far as I know it was
never added to the game and now the
clomballs have gone too so maybe one day
they will return a hidden feature for
over four years was found in 2023 by
Tabor Hill by equipping the bright
bomber set it was possible to fire
firework style Rockets from your glider
epic Discovery many years later speaking
of creators did you know fortnite
streamer reddish was once in a
PlayStation advert back in 2015 look she
'd hear dancing one of fortnite's most
loved characters is Midas during chapter
2 he had a room at the rig in there was
a cabinet containing the Centurion skin
yet a few days before the event it was
removed and eventually it was replaced
with the cyclo skin suggesting Midas
used it during the event but we still
don't have a clue if that's true or not
and Midas seems to have a history of
last minute removals only days before
his character was officially revealed he
was supposed to be wearing glasses yet
the decision was made to remove them by
that point his golden statue was already
an in-game asset so we can still see his
glasses to this day and it gets weirder
Midas has a band of troops loyal to him
known as his first Shadows they were
added in crew packs starting with the
burning wolf he had an animated comic
complete with voiceovers telling us how
he was recruited to the team but
suddenly it was deleted from YouTube all
existence wiped out luckily many of us
downloaded it just in case in fact there
is a real Midas curse and it's in
fortnite King Midas as you know has the
ability to change things into gold just
like the Midas in game well thanks to a
crossover with Tomb Raider it was
possible to have a golden version of
Lara Croft and that was a callback to
this Midas scene did you know the squad
origin set of back blinks are based on
the pin badges the developers received
for working on each season in chapter
one amazing and the Skins include this
jumpsuit in homage to Bruce Lee and in
save the world there's a super rare
collector's version of that yellow
jumpsuit complete with biker helmet this
one is a Kill Bill reference which in
turn is a Bruce Lee reference
remember when the zapatron from save the
world found its way into battle royale
for a few minutes that moment was given
a cheeky Easter egg in fortnite's
imposter mode depicting the rifle in
IELTS holding room and at the end of the
live event that season the zapatron
drifted away in the sea never to be seen
again the Imposter mode had a bunch of
secrets and Easter eggs sticking with
weapons the zap zap energy weapon could
be seen on the wall even though that gun
never appeared in Battle Royale at the
fast food restaurant under the island it
was possible to order a pizza but if you
want pineapple on your pizza the game
has a message for you you're a psycho
and I agree when spider Gwen joined
fortnite we could unlock this
arachrobatic emote which is a group of
impressive flippy flips yet when Gwen
uses the emote the frame rate changes to
match the movie she was last seen in
into the spider-verse a pause is used to
make things look more like a comic book
speaking of spider people when the Evil
Dead crossover was around and players
spoke to Ash wearing a spider outfit Ash
would say you you remind me of a
wrestler I once knew a homage to Toby
Maguire Spider-Man debuting as a
wrestler and look who the announcer is
it's Ash well it's Bruce Campbell but he
plays Ash you get the idea fortnite is
such a massive franchise now that it
appears in movies you'll all Remember
the Time Noob Master 69 was Thor's
fortnite Nemesis in Avengers end game
since then we've seen Ryan Reynolds
summon the rainbow Smash in free guy and
more recently fortnite storyline Master
the mustard we call Donald has been in
The Matrix playing a game developer and
his voice was in Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker and Avengers end game as an
extra that man gets around and of course
he also co-voices the visitor in
fortnite okay I'm gonna blow your mind
right now fortnite does not have any
nipples take a look at these henchmen
none of them have nips I don't know why
this is in the video but it is have fun
trying to get that out of your head oh
do you remember when fortnite added
mouth movements to characters in the
lobby it wasn't there for long but it
was amazing when I talk my mouth moves
when chapter 2 arrived a fridge was
spotted in the middle of the desert and
fans immediately took this as
confirmation Indiana Jones was on his
way of course they were right and when
Indy did arrive a sneaky hidden secret
message was tattooed on his head Liam
and Finn were the love heart from their
dad it didn't take long for epic games
to remove this how dare you show love in
a video game did you know when the
imposters mode released sponsored
streamers were not allowed to say or
reference Among Us at all Epic pretended
they hadn't copied the mode and it
infuriated everyone luckily a few weeks
later this changed and credit was given
to the right game and eventually that
led to a crossover did you know that
Darth Vader can't be shown being hurt or
having weaknesses in fortnite which is
why he has a custom death animation he
takes a knee I'm told this is the same
animation he has in Star Wars
Battlefront and did you know why Vader
helps the Stormtrooper look taller to go
on the roller coaster it's all thanks to
Princess Leia and the time she said this
little short for a stormtrooper huh the
rarest PlayStation trophy in fortnite is
of course the platinum trophy and only
0.1 percent of people have achieved it
it turns out that one of my discard mods
has it I'm not sure if he needs an award
or a hug discard Link in the description
by the way Deadpool once took over
midas's yacht in Chapter 2 he completely
revamped the ship and brought in artwork
you learn about at school including the
scream who said fortnite isn't
educational during the last days of
chapter 3 a lot of the Rings crossover
was hinted at Kid Rock was slowly
building Helms Deep on the beach and
people on Nintendo switch could see the
next part of the build before it updated
but suddenly it was removed they all are
gone did you know the fishing shop in
retail row back in chapter one could be
emoted with to do this when carrying a
chicken and jumping it will regularly
sing Ride of the Valkyries a reference
to the Apocalypse Now war movie the
rarest back blings in fortnite are these
exclusives from fortnite China a shield
and a penguin but since the game isn't
available in China anymore they are all
left in digital Purgatory do they still
exist fortnite once had a secret
storyline about a gnome versus bear War
it spanned months and saw an epic prison
break and a huge battle line drawn up
thankfully peace was declared Loki the
best part of fortnite was all the hidden
stories I loved them another story saw
the Crustaceans go through the stages of
human evolution including building
pyramids and venturing into space and
finally they set off a nuclear blast and
became cyborgs it was so weird but in a
great way when the character V of I
however you say it released she hacked
the fortnite Twitter account to search
for drift a character taken from the
Californian desert all those years ago
they were both part of the fox Clan and
it looked like an epic story was about
to begin but no it was just to sell crew
packs and we never heard anything ever
again and all those tweets were deleted
when John Wick joined fortnite he came
to the island with his own house a near
perfect creation but the best thing of
all was for those who watched the movies
sledgehammering the ground in the
basement revealed Jon's secret hitman's
Dash just like in the movie amazing the
destiny 2 collaboration arrived with a
trailer which showed the iconic loot
cave basically back in Destiny 1 the
drop rate of the best weapons were so
low we would all sit by a cave that
spawned enemies and shoot them for hours
only OG Destiny Gamers understand this
this crossover also saw the fortnite
battle bus crashed land in the destiny 2
reality crazy surreal you've seen the
pink guitar that I wear in game the
original version is blue it's based on
the one used by Dimebag Darrell sadly
the Pantera guitarist was shot in 2004
and the Epic devs wanted to commemorate
the loss R.I.P sorry for the downer
there and to end let's go to the
touchgrass awards for fortnite the
player with the most fortnite Battle
Royale wins as of the day I'm posting
this is ship now with 41
267 wins the most wins in a row is held
by a guy called Ray who is currently on
a 221 game win streak I bought lobbies
allowed the record for most of Limbs in
one match is held by Ranger who has 118
in a single match and the person who has
played the most Fortnight ever that's
Prime salad with 825
740 minutes which is more than 573 days
of constant Fortnight and now you know
why I call these the touching grass
Awards immense dedication is needed that
was 69 Fortnight facts from silly to
sirius I hope you liked it Legends on
screen now who used code adamaru thank
you so much it makes videos like this
possible I'm Adam you're awesome see ya